Democrats call Republicans Bluff on
impeachment procedures an American
military member blasts Trump over
Ukraine and an Obama official calls for
rewriting the First Amendment I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today and expressvpn comm slash Ben okay
so we begin today with impudent Gary
2019 because there are some new
developments these developments are
really two in nature one is the House
Democrats changing their rules and
procedures for the impeachment inquiry
and this has got a lot of Republicans
out there saying things like well if
they're changing the rules this shows
that their rules were insufficient the
first time like they could have just
been transparent from the beginning
obviously they now acknowledge they did
something wrong that's true that's true
there's only one problem which is that
nobody cares the reason nobody cares is
now that emma-crats will simply claim
well you know at the very beginning it
was important that we have behind closed
doors meetings and that we restrict
public views so we could get the early
information but now we're gonna get out
get that out there in public trying to
hang your hat in defense of President
Trump on all this impeachment stuff on
the basis of procedural in Equus
procedural in equities is just a fail
it's not going to work and the reason
it's not gonna work particularly is
because what you are now seeing is
Democrats saying that we're gonna
broaden the procedure so we don't
actually know how the Democrats are
gonna broaden those procedures yet we're
gonna find out on Thursday but for
Republicans to sort of jump both feet in
and suggest that this move by the
Democrats somehow undermines the entire
investigation again it's true that it
shows the Democrats who know they were
doing something wrong from the very
beginning but it is also true that
that's not gonna matter because now
Democrats have opened the doors wide and
said okay here we are let's do this
thing
that is Democrats calling Republicans
Bluff and no amount of sort of puffed up
outrage over Democrats now doing the
right thing is going to detract from
where we go from here in impeachment Kay
2019 so that is development number one
development number two as we're about to
discuss is the testimony of a lieutenant
colonel who's a member of the National
Security Council who is probably the
source for the whistleblower we'll talk
about that in just one second first
let's talk about protecting yourself
online so I'm online like 24/7 I'm
online all the time you probably are too
I mean if you're working in the business
world there's a good shot that you are
online an enormous amount of the time
and when you are online there's a
significant possibility that somebody is
seeking your information whether it is
big data or whether they're just hackers
trying to actually
break into your secure communications
steal data from you if you ever had your
credit card hacked usually that happens
because you're at some sort of public
Wi-Fi and somebody on the public Wi-Fi
is grabbing all of your data and then
using it against you this is why you
ought to be using a VPN and the VPN that
I trust the the fastest VPN the best VPN
is expressed VPN expressvpn runs in the
background of your computer or phone and
then you just use the internet the way
you normally would use yell mode the app
you click to connect and voila you're
now protected
I won't go online without Express VPN
and you should not either Express VPN is
the fastest VPN I've tried it cost less
than seven bucks per month it comes with
a 30-day money-back guarantee expressvpn
uses new cutting-edge technology called
trusted server to make sure there are no
logs with what you do online it's time
to stop hackers Big Brother Internet
companies from grabbing that data take
back your online privacy the same way I
did with expressvpn right now you can
protect your online activity today find
out how you can get three months for
free at expressvpn com /ban that's expr
ESS VPN comm slash been for three months
free with a one-year package again
that's visit expressvpn comm slash Ben
to learn more there's a reason that we
discussed them each and every day on the
program I really do trust the folks over
at Express VPN so as I say House
Democrats said on Monday the house will
vote Thursday to formalize procedures
for the next phase of the impeachment
inquiry into president Trump Democrats
say the move will ensure transparency
and provide a clear path forward this
has prompted the White House to point
out that if the Democrats are so
interested in transparency moving
forward why weren't they interested in
transparency to begin with that is a
fine critique it cuts no weight moving
forward it cuts no weight moving forward
and meanwhile Democrats are focused in
not on the procedural question they're
focused in on the testimony of one
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh
who is Ukraine expert assigned to the
National Security Council he testified
in the House impeachment inquiry on
Tuesday and he offered new details on
the push for investigations of President
Trump's political rivals and
corroborating other witnesses with his
first-hand account of the alleged
attempt at a quid pro quo according to
the Washington Post bin Minh is the
first person to have listened in
personally on the July 25th phone call
between Trump and ukrainian President
Vladimir zalenski
during which from said he wanted a favor
after zalenski broached defense
cooperation between the United States
and Ukraine so apparently bin Minh was
listening from the White House Situation
Room along with other NSC officials and
members
now vice-presidents Pence's staff he
said this in prepared remarks and he
said he was so concerned by the call he
said that it could be seen as a partisan
play that could undermine American
national security he reported it to the
NSCs
lead counsel behind closed doors
according to people familiar with trends
with what transpired again this is why
all of this should be out in the open it
should be televised because we get these
selective leaks VIN Minh also testified
on Tuesday that the contents of the July
25th call differed slightly from what is
stated in the official transcript that
the White House released late last month
so now he's making the claim that the
actual transcript that was released by
the White House which was actually a
call memo the way the data is put
together is a bunch of witnesses to the
call come together and try to
reconstruct from notes and from memory
exactly what was said on the call sound
like they take a recording play it back
and then put together a transcript and
there are some accusations that the
Trump administration had messed around
with the transcript and I had said that
seemed far-fetched cuz there were a lot
of people who were listening to the call
and presumably they all took part in
putting together the transcript VIN Minh
says that the contents of the July 25th
call were in fact slightly different
from the official quote-unquote memo
that the White House released late last
month VIN Minh says that zalenski did
reference Purisima and not just some
nameless company and when Trump pressed
him to investigate former Vice President
Joe Biden's son Hunter hunter the
zolensky responded positively hunter
Biden sat on the board of Purisima a
Ukrainian energy company for some five
years he said that he remembered Trump
going on about how Joe Biden was on tape
boasting about Ukrainian funds which is
probably just a reference to the fact
that Joe Biden is on tape boasting about
how he withheld 1 1 billion dollars in
American loan guarantees Ukraine so
that's nothing really new now here is
the problem for Republicans it's not vin
Minh I mean this is what's so
astonishing everybody is treating the
vin Minh testimony as though this is
something new and shocking well again
we've all seen the transcripts what he
is alleging was different in the
transcript is not all that different
from what we saw in the transcript so
that does not amount to an EXO nion
Watergate cover-up of the actual
contents of the call the contents of the
call were problematic enough right I
mean it wasn't a perfect call it was an
impeachable call but it wasn't a perfect
call by any stretch of the imagination
Trump is doing some pretty blatant and
ugly things in that phone call in my
opinion and we all know about that now
that's not impeachable
it's not impeachable now what Democrats
are doing is they're trotting out
witnesses to the phone call to suggest
that somehow they have some additional
information to add I don't see the
additional information that VIN VIN is
adding the only thing that becomes
pretty clear from VIN Mintz testimony is
that VIN Minh was probably the person
who is talking to the whistleblower
remember the whistleblower was not on
the call he says he spoke to people who
were on the call who are supremely
concerned about the call and then he
reported it up the chain of command
anonymously in another part of the
government so this really isn't about
the whistleblower anymore
probably VIN Minh was talking to the
whistleblower in the first place he says
he wasn't the whistleblower but again
multiple officials apparently were
troubled by the call so is he really
adding anything new to the debate here
the answer is really not not so much I
mean he's sort of doing the same thing
that Bill Taylor was doing from afar or
that Gordon someone was doing he's
adding his gloss to what happened well
now we have the transcript so we sort of
know what happened and we have the text
messages between Bill Taylor and Gordon
sunland's and we know what happened and
we have testimony coming out from people
who are firsthand involved in these
conversations not just people who heard
the conversations so we know what
happened so why is VIN men being trotted
forward well the reason that Democrats
are putting VIN men out there is because
he's a really good-looking witness for
them the reason he's a good-looking
witness is because he's an Iraq war
veteran with a Purple Heart because his
long career in the military and because
he's very much pro aid American aid to
Ukraine so it was almost as though the
Democrats were bringing out Finn Minh
believin hoping that Democrats would
attack women's then they could suggest
that Republicans were willing to attack
an Iraq war veteran with a sterling
career in order to protect president
interim right it's almost it's almost a
catfishing ploy now that's not about
ving Minh then Minh seems like an
honorable dude
I mean VIN Minh served I didn't serve
then Minh was in Iraq I wasn't in Iraq
then been performed heroically in the
field I didn't and I haven't very few
questions about ving Minh as a human
being like I don't see why you would
attack VIN Minh as a witness in fact I
think it's incredibly stupid to do so I
mean the main point to make about VIN
Minh is this dude has no more
information than you or I do he listened
to the phone call we have now seen the
transcript of the phone call and all of
these sort of color commentary that he's
adding about well you know the
transcript left out this little piece or
this little piece from what we are being
told by VIN Minh nothing fun
mentally changes in the text or tenor of
the phonecall based on what happened
during a few of the ellipses and
president Trump immediately fell under
this trap because of course president
Trump is a man who hates exquisitely and
when somebody crosses him he really
attacks him so President Trump went
after this this lieutenant colonel vin
Minh he wrote on Twitter supposedly
according to the corrupt media the
Ukraine call concerned today's that
never Trump or witness was he on the
same call that I was can't be possible
please ask him to read the transcript of
the call witch-hunt now the media are
playing that is the Trump is going after
than men in a serious way he call them a
never Trump er okay that's just that in
the lexicon of President Trump insults
that one really does not rank he just
means somebody who doesn't like him
anytime somebody doesn't like President
Trump doesn't like something he does
President Trump calls him a never Trump
versus it that rise to the level of him
challenging ven-ven's patriotism or
suggesting that Vin min is a bad guy or
something like that well in order to
make that claim you really have to
connect the never Trump or tweet with
the never Trump errs are human scum
tweet from a couple of weeks ago but
when when President Trump goes after
venom in this way is he really attacking
ven-ven's patriotism I'm not seeing that
explicitly at least Trump's tweet
followed assertions on Fox News by a
former Justice Department official named
John you John you was on with Laura
Ingraham and he talked about VIN Minh
and I think that he claims that his
comments are being misinterpreted I
think that is probably correct but here
is what John you had to say about VIN
Minh and about the allegations that the
Ukrainian government was talking to
people like VIN Minh and saying like
what do we do to get our aid here by the
way Ukrainian government it sort of
allowed to do that maybe any claims that
the Ukrainian government is doing
something wrong by going to US officials
and saying listen we don't know what
Trump wants clarify what he wants is
this really what he wants that's not
John use about to say that that's sort
of an espionage operation by the
Ukrainians not by it not by then man but
is that espionage no that's not that's
called normal foreign policy practice
meaning the back-and-forth that happens
between governments and low-level
officials most negotiations don't happen
at the top level anyway here is John you
going after the Ukrainians for the
conversations here we have a US national
security official who is advising
Ukraine while working inside the White
House apparently
against the president's interest and
usually they spoke in English isn't that
kind of an interesting angle on this
story
I find that astounding and you know some
people might call that espionage okay
well when he talks about espionage he
says he's talking about the Ukrainians
reaching out not about ven minh engaging
in espionage or being a traitor or
something you know is it astonishing
that the Ukrainians reached out to
somebody on the National Security
Council to find out what was going on no
that's not astonishing it's not I'm
sorry that's the way to blow this is not
the the typical line that you're hearing
in a lot of conservative media that is
not astonishing in any way it isn't okay
there are plenty of people who are
calling routinely members of the
American foreign policy community trying
to gather information about what they
can do in order to obtain what they want
from the United States as long as the
American officials aren't spilling
confidential information nothing wrong
is going on there really I mean by the
way bill Taylor suggested that he'd had
those sorts of conversations Sunland had
suggested he had those sorts of
conversations in the text messages so I
failed to see that VIN Minh did anything
wrong here I also like again this is so
stupid because the the best Republican
defense on this Trump's best defense is
VIN Minh perceived the phone call
differently than I did that's his
prerogative end of story
that's the whole thing right and until
you get for the 1,000th time Donald
Trump or Rudy Giuliani to testify about
what exactly this whole thing was about
wasn't about investigating president
Trump suspicions about Ukrainian
corruption going back to 2016 which
obviously exercised him or was this
about him hating Joe Biden and wanting
to get Joe Biden and mobilize a foreign
country to prosecute Joe Biden what was
this about perceptions by third-party
players really make no difference here
so the testimony doesn't actually add
anything but Republicans fell into the
trap of attacking the witness which is
exactly what Democrats wanted here I'm
gonna get you more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the
importance of the Second Amendment so as
we're gonna talk about a little bit
later on in the show the Democrats
really do not like the First Amendment a
lot of Democrats want to undermine free
speech they want to undermine freedom of
religion well when the founders enshrine
those freedoms in the end those freedoms
are protected by your vote and if the
government decides to override those
freedoms in the end they are protected
by the Second Amendment when the
founders crafted the Constitution the
first thing they did was to make sacred
the rights of the individual to share
their ideas practice religion without
limitation
that's the First Amendment the Second
Amendment was created to protect those
rights that's why I am a gun owner
because I care about protecting my
rights I care about deterring the
government from violating my rights I
care about protecting myself from people
who would attempt to hurt my family
owning a rifle is an awesome
responsibility and building rifles is no
different started in a garage by a
Marine veteran more than two decades ago
Bravo Company manufacturing BCM for
short builds a professional-grade
product which is built to combat
standards Bravo Company manufacturing is
not a sporting arms company they design
engineer manufactured of life-saving
equipment and about going hunting is
about protecting yourself and protecting
your rights to learn more about Bravo
company manufacturing head on over to
Bravo Company MFG comm you can discover
more about their products special offers
upcoming news that is Bravo Company MFG
comm if you need more convincing find
out even more about BCM and the awesome
people who make their products at
youtube.com slash Bravo Company us a
badass American patriots go check them
out Bravo Company MFG comm Bravo Company
MFG comm ok so the Democrats are very
high on this vin Minh testimony
apparently bin Minh went to the NSA's
lead Council with concerns about a July
10th meeting between Gordon Sunland kurt
volker
who's then a special envoy to Ukraine
Energy Secretary Rick Perry then
National Security Advisor John Bolton
and senior Ukrainian officials during
the meeting according to VIN Men's
prepared statement sunlen demanded that
Ukrainian leaders deliver specific
investigations to secure a meeting
between zalenski and Trump Vanneman says
he was told about the meeting by Sunland
and he says that someone emphasized the
importance that Ukraine's deliver the
investigations into the 2016 election
the Biden's and burries month which is
basically just a complete copy of what
Bill Taylor said right bill Taylor the
highest-ranking official in Ukraine from
America the charge d'affaires in Ukraine
he said exactly the same thing VIN Minh
says I stated to ambassador Sunland that
his statements were inappropriate that
the request to investigate Biden and his
son had nothing to do with national
security and that such investigations
were not something the NSC was going to
get involved in or push is he saying the
same thing that Bill Taylor was saying
so what exactly is special about his
testimony the answer is not a whole hell
of a lot not a whole hell of a lot but
because there have been some Republicans
who have made disparaging remarks about
ven-ven's suggesting that because he is
of Ukrainian American origin that he has
some sort of dual loyalty to Ukraine
that really he cares about Ukraine and
them getting their money he doesn't care
about
America's foreign policy which is silly
I back aid to Ukraine or not from
Ukraine most Republicans back aid to
Ukraine they're not from Ukraine by the
way until the last five minutes Donald
Trump back aid to Ukraine and provided
lethal aid to Ukraine Ian's and their
fight against the Russians President
Trump last I checked is not from Ukraine
it's a bad mistake to do all of us and
of course Democrats are jumping all over
it Joe Biden suggesting that VIN Minh is
a hell of a patriot and that in turning
this into a fight over vindens
patriotism Republicans didn't have to go
here it was a bad political move the way
the present act he did the same thing
with John McCain in 2015 and he did it
was a gold star family moment he did it
with Joe Taylor
now now he this guy won the Purple Heart
this guy is a hero this guy is a patriot
and and but this is just Trump's style
it's the same reason why he has a bunch
of his thugs out there and you know
engaging in this kind of activity and of
intimidation the Giuliani's and cronies
that got arrested I mean this is a it's
despicable to do this - this guy is a
patriot I've never met him but he is the
hell of a patriot
okay well he seems like a patriot and
I'm not really challenging his his
patriotic status I will say that the
celebration of Inman is very different
from the Democrats treatment of military
members and other walks of life suffice
it to say with all of this set the
question becomes okay is any of this
impeachable and we're basically going
around in circles here we're going
around in circles because the bottom
line is until we heard from Giuliani or
Trump and the math changes in some way
it's gonna be very difficult to get
Republican senators on board for
impeachment but that's not really what
this is about in the end what this is
about is democratic misdirection from
the fact that they're gonna be
unbelievably bad at governing the
country because the fact is this whether
or not you believe that President Trump
committed impeachable offense you are if
you're a Democrat what you really don't
want to talk about is your own agenda
because your own agenda is wildly
unpopular with the American people if
you're running an anti Trump campaign
which is smart then you make impeachment
the focal point if you are trying to
push your own ideas you're gonna be in a
lot more trouble if you are a Democrat
and you can see that this is actually
impacting the polls going forward to
2020 according to Axios Republicans are
worried about a quote-unquote
wipe out in 2020 the House the Senate
and the White House House Republicans in
swing districts are retiring at a very
fast pace especially in the suburbs of
Texas and elsewhere there are 19 GOP
House members who are not seeking
re-election at this time around which is
a very high number the Republican Senate
majority suddenly looks like it's in
serious jeopardy because a lot of the
Republicans in swing states are lagging
behind Democrats are raising a lot of
money and pulling better than Republican
incumbents and a lot of the battleground
states president Trump right now in the
polls is trailing every major Democratic
candidate nationally and in the swing
states the the real Senate question is a
problem national Journal's Josh crash
our points out that if Trump doesn't win
a second term Democrats only need to net
three seats to win back the majority
Scott Reid of the US Chamber of Commerce
he says that third quarter fundraising
reports show three Republican senators
being out raised by Democratic
challengers in Arizona Iowa and Maine's
that be Susan Collins and Joni Ernst and
and Martha McKay and martha mcsalley in
Arizona he said we're all very worried
so all of this is scary stuff for
president Trump and for the Republican
Party obviously and Democrats are
excited about all of this because in the
end the more impeachment is in the
headlines the less they are in the
headlines the more you are reading about
denman and attacks on Vanneman and
president Trump railing about all this
on Twitter the less you are thinking
about the fact the paedo are called for
the revocation of every nonprofit status
for every religious charity in America
right the more that you are thinking
about Donald Trump and Ukraine the more
headlines there are about Donald Trump
in Ukraine the less you are thinking
about the fact that Elizabeth Warren
wants to completely decimate the
American economy and that she is a
hypocrite and a liar the more you are
thinking about Ukraine and President
Trump the less you are thinking about
Medicare for all and the complete
takeover of your health care right this
is the the this is what Democrats want
because the more you focus in on the
Democrats unless you want to vote for
them the more you focus in on President
Trump
Democrats assume and the polls tend to
show the less you want to vote for him
so what should Republicans be doing at
this point they should be spending a lot
of their time
of course defending Trump if they
believe that you shouldn't be impeached
right they should of course be defending
Trump from the overwrought accusations
of Democrats at this point but they
should really be spending the bulk of
their time pointing out that there's an
entire
Democratic race going on on this side of
the aisle where Democrats are doing
extremely radical things and we're in
the end let's be practical about this
Republicans in the Senate are not going
to vote to impeach President Trump in
all likelihood it would take a
cataclysmic occurrence you take Rudy
Giuliani going on the hill and saying of
course we have to get Joe Biden right it
would take him literally saying that in
order for me impeachment to take place
which means this thing Peters out at the
beginning of next year and then you are
left with the Democrats running on Trump
is corrupt and Republicans are corrupt
so Republicans have better get their act
together and start campaigning on guys
you know what Democrats want to do if
they actually are in charge of the
country because it's really really scary
toran get some more of this in just one
second I'm gonna explain a few of the
more radical Democratic proposals being
put out there that are moving into the
mainstream pretty quickly first let's
talk about the earbuds you are using to
listen to the show so are you using
those old-fashioned Marty McFly
headphones that pop over your entire ear
they look like earmuffs and you're out
in the middle of a blizzard in winter in
Minnesota or are you using those earbuds
that have the wires and the stems and
you take those you put them in your
pocket and they tangle up and then you
have to unknot it like Alexander the
Great except you can't just cut them
well maybe what you ought to do is check
out ray cons ray Kahn has just released
their best model yet the e25 they have
six hours of play time seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass a more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise-isolating fit ray cons wireless
earbuds are incredibly comfortable they
are perfect for on-the-go listening and
for taking phone calls unlike some of
your other wireless options ray con
earbuds are stylish in a screen no
dangling wires no stems one of things I
like about them they come in a variety
of colors they have a bunch of different
fits so they fit perfectly in your ear
now is the time to get the latest and
greatest from Ray Khan get 15% off your
order at buy rake on Comm slash Ben
that's B you IRA ycl ENCOM / Ben for 15%
off rake on wireless earbuds again
that's by rake on comm / Ben by rake on
comm / Ben okay so as I say Democrats
are focused on impeachment because it's
hurting a lot of the Republicans
according to the hill impeachment is
raising the likelihood the Senate will
be a real battle ground at next year and
the Democrats could regain at the
majority Democrats are gonna lose Doug
Jones a seat in Alabama so that means
they're gonna have to make up for seats
but there are a bunch of vulnerable
incumbents Susan Collins and main core
gardener in Colorado mcsalley in Arizona
Joni Ernst in Iowa and Tom's
in North Carolina four of those people
were outraged by their Democratic
opponents in the third quarter of 2019
all five have higher disapproval than
approval in their home states
Collins is particularly vulnerable she
has a forty nine percent disapproval
rating compared to 43 percent approval
rating if from numbers go down then the
Republicans could lose the presidency
and they could continue to lose the
house and they could lose the Senate
right things could get really ugly
really really quickly so impeachment is
playing for Democrats Republicans had
better shift the conversation pretty
quickly there was this assumption made
by Republicans that the more impeachment
was talked about the better it was for
Trump and Trump made those sorts of
noises early on that is true when the
president has an inherently high level
of popularity going into the impeachment
but if you're Bill Clinton and you're
walking into impeachment with over a 50%
approval rating and then people are like
we got to impeach him your numbers are
gonna go up not down if you are the most
polarizing president in modern American
history and you are already riding it
like forty-one percent in the polls and
then people start talking impeachment
over you being you on a phone call with
Ukraine the numbers are gonna go down
and ain't gonna it's not gonna work the
same way I'm just you know I'm not going
to lie to people about what the polls
show when it comes to approval for
impeachment improvable for impeachment
shows right now a majority of Americans
okay a majority of Americans now say
according to most polls that they are
willing to see trump impeach now does
that actually mean that this is true in
each state not really but it's damaging
Trump even in the states where they
don't approve impeachment so for example
there is a poll that was just done in
Arizona and the poll shows that the that
the people of Arizona are giving from
very low marks but by the same by the
same token they don't want to see him
impeach but that really doesn't matter
if he's not getting impeached
okay impeachment is a proxy for do you
like the president or not at the highest
available level hey over at 5:38 the
Democrat the columnist Amelia Thompson
at DeVoe she does piece called why
Democrats are moving quickly with
impeachment and she says because they're
attempting to they're attempting to get
this done before primary season really
opens up because they understand that
that Republicans are going to vote this
thing down and so they may as well
simply get this thing
over with so they can run on the basis
of it so how should Republicans respond
to all of us well they should respond in
a few ways one they should respond by
defending Trump on the merits but they
should as I say make the case that I
have made which is the only plausible
case which is that when it comes to
Trump's activities in Ukraine he
basically has what you might call the
UFO theory of Ukraine right if the
presidents of the United States urged a
foreign country to investigate UFOs
because the United States was very
interested in the presence of UFOs would
that be like a waste of time and money
probably would that be impeach abaut not
really the president would claim it's
legit interest of the United States to
find out about UFOs well the same thing
is sort of happening in Ukraine right
Trump there are legit inquiries to be
made about Ukrainian Ukrainian
corruption Joe Biden Purisima
CrowdStrike are those among them
CrowdStrike almost certainly not Joe
Biden in Purisima mmm but overall
Ukrainian corruption yes right so that
was always Trump's defense is that in my
mind I have this whole ball of
corruption that is in my head we should
go after all of it right that's always
Trump's best defense that's what he
should be saying and then he should be
moving on to the generalized fact that
Democrats are talking impeachment not
because they're good at their jobs but
because they're very very bad at their
jobs right that is the real problem here
okay so now let's talk about that
Democratic agenda first of all let's
talk about the sudden concern that
Democrats have over foreign interference
with America's electoral system and
foreign interference with regard to
America's politics okay remember all the
way back to the 1990s when Bill Clinton
and Hillary Clinton were involved
allegedly in a scheme to funnel Chinese
money into the u.s. election in 1996
that did not result in Clinton's
impeachment
well now we're finding out that when
Barack Obama was re-elected in 2012 a
Saudi tycoon and his business associate
sent hundreds of thousands of dollars to
the United States to help pay for the
inaugural celebration and get a picture
with the president according to court
documents and an analysis of campaign
finance records by The Associated Press
u.s. election law prohibits foreign
nationals from making those sorts of
political contributions but the
donations Sheikh Mohammed Al Rabbani
tried to send to Obama's inaugural
committee were funneled through seasoned
straws owner instead the intermediary
Ahmad
Jabari agreed this month to plead guilty
to making illegal campaign contributions
to several American
candidates on behalf of foreign
nationals he has also set to plead
guilty to concealing his work as a
foreign agent as he lobbied high-level
US government officials he served as ooh
buried by the way served as a top
fundraiser for both Obama and Hillary
Clinton during their presidential runs
including stints on both of their
campaign finance committees and then he
switched his support to Trump
immediately after the 2016 victory so
what does this mean it means that
corruption unfortunately is sort of rife
in American politics and as Americans
feel that way they are less likely to
believe that Trump has done something
utterly utterly without precedent okay
with that with all of that said where
should Republicans be focusing right now
as I say half on impeachment and half on
the Democrats agenda because the
Democrats agenda right now is so
terrible and so awful and so bad and now
they're coming out of the woodwork
they're getting confident now Democrats
are getting confident they're saying the
quiet part out loud whether it's bado
saying that he wants to remove nonprofit
status from every religious charity in
America or whether it's Richard Stengel
former editor of Time magazine and State
Department undersecretary for public
diplomacy and public affairs under Obama
from 2013 to 2016 so that you would
imagine as the undersecretary for public
diplomacy and public affairs he'd be
very much in favor of free speech
wouldn't you wrong he has a piece today
in the Washington Post titled why
America needs a hate speech law he says
as a government official traveling
around the world championing the virtues
of free speech I came to see how our
First Amendment standard is an outlier
even the most sophisticated Arab
diplomats that I dealt with did not
understand why the First Amendment
allows someone to burn a Quran why they
asked me would you ever want to protect
that it's a fair question
no it's not actually a fair question
your right to free speech pre-exists
government see this is the problem when
you're a Democrat when you're on the far
left you believe that your rights come
from government so why should government
allow you to do things that's not the
question they cover the question is what
gives government the right to invade
your rights and that's the question
you're getting at ass-backwards richard
engel he says yes the First Amendment
protects the thought that we hate but it
should not protect hateful speech that
can cause by violence by one group
against another so now he's not even
claiming the incitement the violence is
the standard he's saying that if I burn
a Koran which I wouldn't do by the way
because why would I burn Quran like
perfectly decent book not
like I'm not a book burner but if I were
to burn in Quran and then a Muslim would
kill somebody over it that would not be
a that would not be my fault
that would not be my fault okay that's
it that's an absurdity but that's what
richard engel is suggesting this is
basically the hecklers veto if you say
something and people go fight about it
then we should outlaw that speech he
says in an age when everyone has a
megaphone that seems like a design flaw
he says it's important to remember our
First Amendment doesn't just protect the
good guys our foremost Liberty also
protects any bad actors who hide behind
its weak in our society in the weeks
leading up to the 2016 election russia's
internet research agency planted false
stories hoping they would go viral they
did Russian agents assumed fake
identities promulgated false narratives
and spread lies on Twitter and Facebook
all protected by the First Amendment
the Russians understood that our free
press and it's reflex for balance and
fairness would enable mosque out to slip
its destructive ideas into our media
ecosystem when Putin said back in 2014
there were no Russian troops in Crimea
and outright lie he knew our media would
report it and we did um so let me get
this straight
because some people uncritically
repeated Vladimir Putin's lies in 2014
that means that we have to outlaw
American speech so basically any
information that richard engel doesn't
like should be considered hate speech
and then ban in the united states well
I've been saying for a while the First
Amendment is under severe attack by the
hard left in this country and it's not
gonna remain on the hard left very long
it is going to skew over into the
mainstream left it incredibly quickly
it's already done this in the UK as well
as Canada where there are serious
questions about whether you can raise
your child as a boy if your boy if your
boy is a biological boy and claims you
as a girl and then you say well no I
have a right to raise my child the way
that I want in Ontario theoretically
that kid could be taken away from you
okay in the United States we have a
First Amendment the protects freedom of
religion and freedom of speech but you
can see that the left doesn't like those
amendments very much which is why the
New York City Human Rights Commission
keeps passing all of these regulations
suggesting they will find you a quarter
of a million dollars if you
intentionally misgender somebody or
something or if you use the term illegal
alien anyway Richard Engel continues
that all of this is is because the First
Amendment was engineered for a simpler
era this is what you constantly heard
from the left by the way things are too
complex to rely on the Constitution no
they're not
the Constitution was written with a
baseline understanding of human nature
the left believes that the Constitution
is wrong that's all that's happening
here but their understanding of human
nature and the Constitution is wrong but
according to returned angle we should
just get rid of the First Amendment
he says the amendment rests on the
notion the truth will win out in what
Supreme Court Justice William O Douglas
called the marketplace of ideas the
marketplace model has a long history
going back to the 17th century English
intellectual John Milton but in all that
time no one ever quite explained how
good ideas drive out bad ones
how truth triumphs over falsehood Milton
an early opponents of censorship said
truth would prevail in a free and open
encounter a century later the framers
believed that this marketplace was
necessary for people to make informed
choices in a democracy somehow magically
truth would emerge the presumption has
always been made that the marketplace
would offer a level playing field but in
the age of social media that landscape
is neither fair nor level so in other
words he doesn't trust people to make a
decision so he's gonna control what you
ought to see he's gonna control how you
access information he says since world
war ii many nations have passed laws to
curb the incitement of racial and
religious hatred these laws started out
as protections against the kinds of
anti-semitic bigotry that gave rise to
the Holocaust we call them hate speech
laws but there's no agreed-upon
definition of what hate speech actually
is in general hate speech is speech that
attacks and insults people on the basis
of race religion ethnic origin and
sexual orientation I think it's time to
consider these statutes
he says the modern standard of dangerous
speech comes from Brandenburg versus
Ohio and holds that speech that directly
incites imminent lawless action or as
likely to do so can be restricted
he says the domestic terrorists like
Dylan Ruth and Omar Mateen and the El
Paso shooter were consumers of hate
speech speech doesn't pull the trigger
but does anyone seriously doubt that
hateful speech creates a climate or such
acts are more likely let the debate
begin hate speech has a less violence
but nearly as damaging impact in another
way it's a minister's tolerance it
enables discrimination why shouldn't the
states experiments with their own
version of hate speech statutes to
penalize speech that deliberately
insults people based on religion race
ethnicity and sexual orientation all
speech is not equal and where the truth
cannot drive out lies must add new
guardrails I'm all for protecting
thought we hate but not speech that
incites hate so in other words he's not
for he's not for protecting thought we
hate but he's not because his standard
of incitement is extraordinary
we brought this is the world Democrats
want this is what Republicans should be
pointing out this is where their chief
focus should be not on impeachment great
219 all the information isn't out once
all the information is out then put your
focus there but right now where should
Republicans be putting their focus in
the fact that this is the America the
Democrats want is Richard angles America
and that scares the living hell out of
me as it should you I don't want those
people in charge of the federal
government or any government for that
matter get some more of this in one
second first let's talk about that great
day back when you were 13 years old you
got those braces off and you're like oh
man I'm never gonna wear those ugly
terrible braces they cut my cheeks and
they look terrible at a metal mouth it's
just awful and your orthodontist is like
and also remember what where these
retainers and then a week later you were
brushing your teeth and you accidentally
knock the retainers in the toilet and
rather than reaching it at the toilet
you're like huh well I guess that's that
and now it's 20 years later your teeth
are all out of alignment well maybe you
should be considering candid canids
aligners can help straighten your teeth
faster than traditional wire braces
treatment takes just six months on
average an experienced orthodontist
licensed in your state creates a custom
treatment plan then they show you a 3d
preview so you can see how your teeth
will look after you're done candids
aligners are comfortable and removable
and completely invisible candy chips
your aligners directly to you so there's
no hassle of going to an orthodontist
office and canden cost 65% less than
braces with each aligner purchase by the
way Kenz it also will donate 25 bucks to
smile train they bring safe 100% free
cleft lip and palate treatments of kids
around the globe which is a really
awesome thing to do I'm gonna have that
photo-ready smile ready by the holidays
I've been using canted they make it
really easy you can to go to candid
co.com slash Shapiro and use Coach
Shapiro to get 75 bucks off that is
candid co.com slash Shapiro code Shapiro
for 75 bucks off again candid co.com
slash Shapiro code Shapiro okay
we're going to get into other Democratic
plans for the future that should scare
the living hell out of you this is why
they were focusing on impeachment and
not on their own policy preferences
we'll get to that in just a minute first
go over to daily wear comm and subscribe
you know that you know the drill $9.99 a
month ninety-nine bucks a year plus we
have this magical daily wire app that
gives you special access to me and to
our writers you can access all of our
content including articles and and
backgrounds from the shows and more
straight from the app and the all-access
subscribers get our new exclusive
discussion features where you can
interact directly with people like me
the app is
available from Apple and Android
downloaded today become a subscriber
come and join the fun it is indeed a
blast ninety-nine bucks a year also gets
you this the very greatest in all
beverage vessels go check it out right
now we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so again as I mentioned Democratic
agenda focus on the Democratic agenda
how has President Trump not tweeted out
yet about Richard angle and Obama
official overtly saying he wants to
overthrow the First Amendment in favor
of a cadre of brilliant leftists
figuring out what you can and cannot say
and then there are their economic takes
there's an article by a guy named
Stephen Mihm over at Bloomberg today
Bloomberg not Bloomberg economics called
a wealth tax could deliver a happiness
dividend you getting this so the
question is not whether the wealth tax
is a good economic idea whether its
constitutional feasible or anything it's
that it will make people happy when you
see that rich people are being punished
I mean for that matter we could just put
out some stocks in public drag Bill
Gates to them and just sit him down and
then those things we know throw Rotten
Tomatoes at him it'd be super fun
basically we could take the Aristo x'
and we could put them in this this thing
called the guillotine and we could just
behead them to the cheers of the rabble
that seems like that would also create a
Happiness dividend for the for the non
bourgeois for another non boos huazi
according to Stephen Mihm tax the rich
plans phased out about the amount of
money they could raise but Richard
Reacher's researchers say they
dependably produce an emotional lift for
society as a whole oh well you know so
long as we pursue policies that are
completely ineffective and also punish
wealth creation but make people who were
not involved in that wealth creation
feel really good we should totally do it
in fact we should hold public spankings
and we need to bring Jeff Bezos out and
we need to get the paddle from fifth
grade in 1972 and we need to whap Jeff
Bezos around a few times wouldn't that
be fun
like we could all have some fun with
that said Stephen Mihm when a study
released earlier this month showed the
wealthiest Americans paying a lower tax
rate than any other group Democratic
presidential candidates embraced it as
proof they were on the right track well
their tax the rich proposals vowed to
create a better economic balance the
candidates often pivot to what they
would do with the proceeds Medicare for
all student loan relief infrastructure
repair other expensive programs those
equations have raised serious doubts for
a good reason
turning tax revenue into a massive
health care system or a measurable
economic growth is incredibly
complicated but raising taxes on the
wealthy could deliver something
meaningful that millions of Americans
would rather feel quickly happiness
recent research found that progressive
may make the average citizen happier and
more content in the course of their
study psychologists Shigure hero Oshie
and close studying Koosh lev of the
university of virginia and Orick jamak
of the university of toronto issued the
usual debate over tax increases are they
bad for economic growth instead they
focus on a more emotional one -
Americans feel happier and experience a
greater sense of fairness under more
progressive taxation and what they found
is a very strong correlation between
progressive tax policies and how happy
respondents rated themselves this effect
was most pronounced and statistically
significant among taxpayers in the
lowest 40% of incomes no you're kidding
me you mean people who earn the least
are really happy to see people who earn
a lot of money punished publicly no you
mean the worst in human instinct is
given free rein when you punish people
for success the correlation steadily
diminished among higher-income groups
disappearing altogether for the top
forty percent by the way this does
reveal a certain truth but it's not the
truth that people on the Left think it
reveals so people aren't left like well
that's because we have an innate sense
of fairness when we see somebody who's
rich and somebody who's poor we
immediately think that they should share
the wealth
write me and said when you're a kid and
there were two cookies and there were
two of you and you need to share the
cookies but what this actually reveals
is that people who tend to get ahead in
American society our people who are not
spending their time focusing in on how
much wealth other people are making
they're spending their time building up
businesses and trying to forge careers
if you spend your time being jealous of
people who have more wealth than you
believe me there's an endless supply of
there are a lot of people who are richer
than I am and five years ago there were
a lot more people mad were richer than I
was and you can either spend your time
bitching about it or you could spend
your time going out and making the
wealth and it's funny this actually look
it violates one of the Ten Commandments
the the ninth commandment which is that
the tenth commandment you shall not
covet thy neighbor's property
okay the tenth commandment is pretty
specific about this in Jewish law this
doesn't mean that you're not allowed to
covet the kind of thing your neighbor
has if my neighbor has a Ferrari and I'm
like god that's an amazing car I wish I
had that car that is not a violation of
the 10th commandment it is a violation
of the 10th commandment if I say I
really want that car that's my car right
that's good that sort of covetousness
was always considered to be a vice under
most classical traditions of virtue but
we put that aside now it's well if you
if you covet your neighbor's car well in
you should probably just go ahead and
take it or ishii to authorize the
government to go ahead and take and then
you'll feel better then you'll feel like
there's the old Solomonic tale I'm only
going back to the Bible here because the
judeo-christian roots of our morality
are pretty deeply embedded
there's this old Solomonic tale that I'm
sure you've all heard in which King
Solomon is confronted with this bizarre
case a there are two women and they live
in in sort of an apartment complex and
they both have babies at the same time
and one of the women's babies dies and
the other woman claims that and the
other woman's baby lives and both women
claim that the live baby is theirs in
the dead baby is the baby of the other
person and so Solomon calls forth one of
his guards and he says I want you to
take this living baby and I want you to
cut it in half and one of the mother
says absolutely do it and the other
mother says no give the baby to the
other mama better that the baby should
live then that I should have the baby
and Solomon says obviously that one's
the mother and when one comes to wealth
the same principle holds if you are into
the division and destruction of wealth
simply because you are jealous that
somebody else has some you are doing
decency virtue and economics wrong but
apparently that what the left would like
is world where you feel better about
yourself because somebody else has their
wealth taken away so they're not a fan
of the First Amendment they're not a fan
of economic freedom how the right isn't
honing in on this is simply beyond me
especially because again these
Democratic candidates are incredibly
vulnerable on a variety of scores
democratic governance just it just does
not work even the cases where Democrats
suggest that the solution is bigger
government that's just not true like
right now Democrats are busily
suggesting that the situation in
California where PG and E which is
Pacific Gas and Electric a semi private
company I'll explain why semi private in
just a second that PG&E is under severe
flak because they've been shutting down
their power grids cuz they haven't
updated the power grids in like 100
years this is leading Democrats feel
like we should nationalize the utilities
this shows that profit-seeking companies
are really really bad but as The Wall
Street Journal points out in an article
written by Alyssia Finley she says PG&E
exemplifies the left stakeholder model
according to which businesses are
accountable not only to shareholders but
also to workers the environment and
local communities and society at large
in California utilities are the most
heavily regulated businesses their rates
and return on equity are set by the
California Public Utilities Commission
and the Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission every three years PG&E must
submit funding plans to the CPUC which
holds public hearings with quote-unquote
stakeholders including customers and
activist groups the Commission and state
legislature dictate energy investments
state law requires utilities to obtain
60% of their power from renewable
sources by 2030 plus the Commission has
ordered utilities to buy energy from
home homeowners with solar panels
meaning that they are paying a higher
rate than wholesale power providers get
last year the Commission instructed PG&E
to install 7500 electric car charging
stations and apartment buildings and
workplaces so if shareholders want to
earn a profit they have to indulge their
political masters fashionable views on
matters like climate identity politics
and corporate governance the utility
proclaims a diversity and inclusion our
Integra R integral to how we do business
they talk about environmental justice
focusing in on low-income communities
and communities of color well it turns
out that when you heavily regulate and
subsidize businesses you basically made
them into arms of the state the utility
mainly donates to Democrats the Human
Rights Campaign gave the utility one
hundred percent rating on his Corporate
Equality Index from 2003 to through 2018
Democrats have blasted PG&E for spending
millions on political lobbying but much
of the advocacy has been in support of
the state's climate goals including
consumer electric car driven subsidies
and fuel economy mandates so again
Democrats are ripping on the profit
sensors supposedly at these utilities
but this is just another case of bad
democratic governance so here's the deal
if you'd like a first amendment governed
by richard Rangel if you'd like an
economy governed by people who are
mostly happy just to take down wealth
and if you are really into the kind of
governments that led to PG&E shutting
off the power on millions of customers
in the last couple weeks in California
by all means elect a Democrat by all
means do this thing because this is the
world the Democrats want and after all
the impeachment stuff is over and again
the chances of Trump actually being
removed from office are incredibly low
after all the impeachment stuff is over
the only thing that is going to matter
is whether is whether Americans prefer
the governance of Democrats to the
government it's the governance of
President Trump so Republicans need to
refocus and this is what they should be
focusing on
and they have a lot to focus on a lot to
focus on even Democrats are aware how
weak their own candidates are at this
point like the New York Times is a full
piece today lamenting the fact that no
top-tier Democrats in the 2020 race are
minorities they're blaming implicit bias
among Democrats apparently Democrats are
secret racists for not liking Kamala
Harris or Cory Booker but they're
front-running candidates are in our in a
world of hurt they're just not good Kent
so let's take an example Elizabeth
Warren right now is widely perceived to
be the frontrunner for the nomination
well Elizabeth Warren is being now
called out for her corporate cronyism
four years or choose taking something
like half a million dollars from major
corporations particularly one company
named Ltd Steele which we talked about
yesterday on the podcast in which the
New York Times dived into Warren's
previous work for LTV they said to
settle a quote miners strike the federal
government forged an agreement that
miners would have health care coverage
when they retired provided by their last
employer and then LTV went bankrupt and
they stopped paying LTV objected so
called in to defend all of this was
Elizabeth Warren she joined the
company's legal team in 1995 and then
she proceeded to rip on LTV in 2006
here's Elizabeth Warren eleven years
later ripping on the very company that
she actually represented in the
bankruptcy hearings to riding LTVs
bankruptcy as the epitome of broken
promises to workers according to Tommy
Christopher over at mediate because
what's happened is now it's time to pay
the piper LTV is just the first of many
that we're going to see along these
lines where the question is what happens
to all those promises you made to the
employees when this steel business
simply will not support that kind of
payment LTV showed how you could lock up
all the assets so that essentially the
company could say we're broke the
cupboards bare
there's nothing here and use those
assets put them back in the operation to
create a newer more profitable company
weird that's a combination wrapped in
1995 very odd it's almost as though
she's wildly dishonest which leaves it
to people like John Legend to talk about
the reason why people are not getting
behind Elizabeth Warren is cuz men feel
by women John Legend political
commentator so just what what what a
delight what a delight he says why do
men feel threatened by women she's the
best candidate running today is
Elizabeth Warren sure I'm sure this is
all about men feeling threatened by
women legend said honestly I don't
comprehend why a guy hate guys hate
women so much sometimes you see someone
as transparently competence in eloquence
and on fire as Elizabeth Warren and then
you hear some guys just are not into
voting for a woman why do guys feel so
threatened by the idea of a woman
president and Chrissy Teigen his wife
said our menses because there's ten days
a month where we're just going to war
yeah I'm sure that's it it can't be that
Elizabeth Warren is wildly dishonest it
can't be that at all what I what a bunch
of nonsense by the way if you if you
thought Bernie Sanders is honest he's
not honest either so I've said he's the
most honest of the Democratic candidates
that doesn't mean he's actually honest
Bernie Sanders yesterday was asked about
his plan to pay for Medicare for all
he's like I'm not going to show you the
doctor plan why why would I show you the
plan to pay for this thing
we all know we're gonna kill the rich
people and eat them that's what this
money is coming from the fight right now
is to get the American people to
understand that we're spending twice as
much per capita but of course we can pay
for it we're paying it now in a very
reactionary regressive way I want to pay
for it in a progressive way now you're
asking me to come up with an exact
detailed plan of how you know every
America much you're gonna pay more than
that I don't think I have to do that
right now okay so um yeah he doesn't
have to do it he's just not going to
explain the plan there's so much rich
material for Republicans what they have
to do is get past this impeachment thing
what that means is what they should be
doing right now
it's just shutting up seriously I
understand that Trump is clamoring for
them to be shouting from the rooftops
about impeachment is is a hoax and it's
a witch-hunt and all of this stuff while
Republicans should do is basically the
same thing they did during the mall or
investigation this is what they did they
just said okay well wait for all of it
to come out and then we'll make a
judgement because the Democrats are
gonna do it anyway and the more focus is
brought to the impeachment stuff the
worse it is for Republicans just on a
public-relations level well you actually
want is for the Republicans to say okay
bring all this stuff forth we'll hear it
all and then we'll make a decision in
all likelihood it's like it would be
very difficult to imagine a situation in
which you get a majority Republican
Senate to vote for Trump's impeachment
and meanwhile focus in on the fact that
these 20 20
Democrats are insane they spent the last
48 hours appealing to J Street which is
a front group for anti-israel sources I
mean it's just it's it's astonishing to
me that the the personality whims of the
president Ricci wants everybody out
there on the front lines cheering and
pouring hot oil and all of this about
impeachment when the information isn't
out there yet
it's not going to be to his benefit I
think someone has to say no here's what
we should be talking about because
there's plenty to talk about on the
other side of the aisle okay time for a
quick thing that I hate and then a quick
thing that I like and we will get out of
here in fact let's do things I like
first so a couple of things that I like
first of all the NCAA has made a good
decision that I've been calling for for
a long time that is to allow the
student-athletes to capitalize on their
own image frankly was an absurdity that
student athletes were not allowed to do
this that it was treated as though when
Zion Williamson was a Duke that Zion
Williamson was getting the benefit of
the Duke education and that is why he
shouldn't be able to capitalize on his
image but the n-c-double-a should hey
that was just it was ridiculous
okay Zion Williamson wasn't there to get
his degree in business management sign
Woodson there was there to play
basketball and then move on to the NBA
which is why there are so many people in
college basketball who are doing this
one-and-done routine and they're going
in for a year or they go in for two
years and then they go directly to the
NBA by the way they should totally do
that if you have a skill set I'm not a
believer that you have to stay in
college just to stay in college if it
worked for Bill Gates why shouldn't it
work for Zion Williamson I've always
thought it's bizarre that people are so
concerned and when people talk about
implicit bias I've always thought it's
very bizarre people are very concerned
about how many basketball players go to
college as opposed to for example how
many baseball players go to college and
the answer is a lot of baseball players
go direct high school to the minor
leagues now if you want to go into a
college basketball if you want to go
into the n-c-double-a to get prepped for
a year or two for your own benefit that
seems reasonable to me but it also seems
more than reasonable that you should be
able to own your own image you shouldn't
forfeit that right simply because you
play college basketball
it's really silly the whole division
between amateur and professional is
really quite ridiculous
in this context let's be real about this
Duke uses people Xin Williamson as an
actual as an actual professional athlete
they make money off Sian Williams and
there is money from Zion Williamson
there's no
and why Sian Williamson shouldn't make
money off his own image while he's in
college so I'm glad the n-c-double-a has
changed that rule other things that I
like so this is just hilarious
president Trump was greeted by a kid
dressed as one of the minions from
Despicable Me
so is Melania and he obviously didn't
know what to do and so he was handing in
cake candy and he and Melania take candy
and put it on the head of the minion his
little kid who's walking around a minion
costume it's pretty funny here's what it
looked like okay so there is president
Trump Melania here comes one of these
kids dressed as a minion and Trump takes
a candy bar and puts it on the head of
the minion and then Melania does the
same thing it promptly slides off while
the kid reaches for it you could just
put it in the bag like you could adjust
solid stuff solid stuff right there okay
time for a couple of quick things that I
hate okay so I need to read you these
new lyrics so now we've been told that
baby it's cold outside
he's quite quite bad very bad very not
me too very awful so now Kelly Clarkson
and John Legend have redone baby it's
cold outside because it was a rapey song
right it was rapey because he was he was
trying to get this woman into bed and
she kept talking about she wanted to go
but she was warmed by the fire and
except for you know every human
relationship which has vagaries of
wooing we're all supposed to believe
that that that this is a super that he's
trying to date rape her right she that
the whole argument is about a man trying
to wheedle a woman into bed which has
never happened in the history of man by
the way no man has ever wheedled women
into bed normally when you have sex with
with a girl the way that it works is
that you actually get out of contract
notarized by your attorney and then you
have her check particular boxes as to
which activities she would seek to
participate in that's not sufficient you
then have to stop before each step and
make sure that she is still okay with it
right you need affirmative consent in
California they've been trying to pass
this yes means yes law for years in
which you actually have to get quote
unquote
affirmative consent it's not enough for
a woman to enthusiastically participate
in the event you have to get affirmative
verbal consent for each step which is
just hot man I mean there's nothing
quite as hot as do you mind if I do
exactly this and then you're like I
consent that I mean that is some sexy
stuff so the
it's cold outside is just a clever song
about a man and a woman and the man
wooing the woman and it is like this is
like here's that here's that here's the
part where people get really uptight
right the woman sings I ought to say no
no no sir
because women have never said that
before ever right women have never said
that they ought to say no but their
heart says yes that's never happened in
the history of mankind it's not how 75%
of pregnancies and the history of
mankind have ever happened and then the
man says my sister she says my sister
will be suspicious and he sings gosh
your lips look delicious and then she
says say what's in this drink now
people read that is like he's drugging
her or alternatively she is trying to
make excuses for the fact that she
actually wants to stay and that she's
lightheaded and woozy and that really
she's in love with the guy right maybe
that's what the song is about in any
case they've now redone the lyrics and
made them significantly worse
okay so Kelly Clarkson and John Legend
have made this because we have to take
everything incredibly seriously and we
have to assume but I do love that we're
supposed to believe the baby it's cold
outside
leads to a vast women hating culture of
rape but rap lyrics do not right we're
not gonna rewrite any of the and
hoe lyrics from rap not gonna rewrite
any of that stuff because that's
fighting come on why would we do that
that's just that's just a part of
America's rich musical lexicon but baby
it's cold outside I can't tell you how
many times serial rapist like Harvard
Harvey Weinstein hit the button baby
it's cold outside comes on and he
immediately just goes on and does his
thing like what okay so here is the new
lyric in the reimagined version Clarkson
sings quote I've got to go away and
legend responds I can call you a ride
hot hot sexy sexy and then Clarkson
sings what will my friends think and
legend says I think they should rejoice
and she says if I have one more drink
and he says it's your body your choice
ah just that sizzles doesn't it it's
your body your choice abortion slogans
in the middle of a woollen session hot
the new lyrics were written by legend
and the comedian Natasha Rothwell of
insecure it's just ridiculous it's just
ridiculous a San Francisco station that
dropped the song last year reversed
course after most listeners said they
wanted the song in rotation Susan lesser
who is
daughter of Frank Lazar one of the great
songwriters in American history he's
responsible for all the songs in Guys
and Dolls he's responsible for the most
happy fellow a lot of great American
musicals written by Frank Loesser one of
the great songwriters in American
history
Susan Lester said way before me too I
would hear from time to time people call
it a date-rape song I'd get annoyed
because it's a song my dad wrote for him
and my mother to sing at parties she
says people used to say what's in this
drink as a joke she went on you know
this drink is going straight to my head
so what's in this drink back then it
didn't mean you drugged me correct
correct
nobody has taught that n a roofie song
it's so absurd
I like really John Legend and Kelly
Clarkson it's your body your try those
lyrics I can call you a ride your uber
is outside like what okay you guys
you're taking things too seriously
you're taking things much much much too
seriously but the good news is Richard
angle wants to outlaw the song
presumably as a form of hate speech so I
think these are the people who should we
should we should have in charge of our
fundamental debates about the nature of
speech are people who think that baby
it's cold outside is a real problem but
the lyrics of jay-z are not only
acceptable but but absolutely praise
worthy rain American figures include
Snoop Dogg in his lyrics but Frank
Loesser raped me super raping yeah or
everybody's just full of crap one of
those two things okay one final thing
that I hate so the the far left is
insane on the topic of Israel and they
are fully willing to go anti-semitic on
it a students for justice in students
for justice in Palestine remember this
is a far left anti Israel Israel hating
terror supporting group the SJP they are
not students they are not for justice
and they're not for peace the only part
of that did the only part of their title
that means anything is the Palestine
part an activist confronted a Holocaust
survivor so the Holocaust survivor was a
defender of Israel you know why because
a lot of Jews in the aftermath of it
like particularly Holocaust survivors
tend to be supporters of Israel can you
can you think of a reason why maybe
Holocaust importers to Holocaust
survivors tend to be supporters of
Israel like maybe the fact that during
the Holocaust every country closed its
doors to Jews attempting to escape Nazi
Germany including British Mandate
Palestine and that the establishment of
the Jewish state means that we'll never
have
again maybe that's the reason why
Holocaust survivors are sort of
supporters of Israel and heavy measure
well in SJP activists whose greatest
hardship has been at one time their
iphone broke confronts a holocaust
survivor about palestinian ethnic
cleansing by the jewish state now let me
just be clear I'm in Israel right now I
cannot think of a larger a larger lie
than the idea that Israel is performing
ethnic cleansing against the
Palestinians you have to be out of your
mind to believe this there's some what
four to five million Palestinians living
in Judea Samaria and Gaza okay so that's
a that's a horrible job of ethnic
cleansing Israel terrible terrible job
it turns out that Palestinians are
reproducing at a much faster rate than
Jews and have been for decades at this
point their cities are growing by the
way the cities are kind of nice I mean
I've driven past a bunch of them they
look a lot better than they did I was
last year in 2001 the cities at that
point did not look very good a lot of
these cities are brand new a lot of them
look quite beautiful the the city of
Hebron which is a major Palestinian
center two hundred fifteen thousand
Palestinians has like a mall with a KFC
like a lot of the stuff that you're told
about the inherent poverty that's
happening here is just not true there is
no ethnic cleansing going on but here is
the students in justice in Palestine
activists confronting a Holocaust
survivor virtually signaling all over
somebody who survived Hitler because and
the idea of Dyan ism ties back to the
right of the palate that Israeli state
in at any cost
and that cost is the Palestinian people
i under I am a result of experiences
that you have been through I am a
survivor of the Intifada and that is it
way after 1948 when the path of
Palestinian land was occupied I went
through minimal amounts of things at the
edge the Palestinian people historically
went through and I'm asking you and it's
not pointing to know that a Holocaust
survivor would would remain neutral in a
situation of in just about a matter of
neutral it's a matter of I think the two
sides have been really were
for experience tonight it's not total
guilt or innocence on either side the
establishment does not like feeling and
also that there are people are much more
expert in dish and I always yes she's
accusing him of backing ethnic cleansing
and it's it's fully insane okay the
claims that she is making there by the
way that she's a survivor of the
Intifada you know the Intifada was
declared by Yasser Arafat in the
Palestinians it wasn't Israel but
declared the Intifada if you're a
survivor of the unspotted you might want
to blame the Palestinian leadership
which turned down the best peace deal
they will ever receive from a hood Barak
including the division of Jerusalem and
then instead opted for a massive
outbreak of violence ending in the death
of thousands of Palestinians and
thousands of Jews as well so yeah this
sort of nonsense the fact that the left
gives credence to it demonstrates how
many lives they're willing to buy into
in the name of social justice warrior
woken us okay we'll be back here later
to deal with two additional hours of
content I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo wide outski
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
see him the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 on the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all the things that
are really important to you so come join
the conversation